Have you ever stopped and, you
know, really thought about how
the exact same thing, the same
action done by two different
people can get such wildly
different reactions?
I mean, we're talking about
something pretty
straightforward, right?
Streets getting cleaned, maybe
homeless encampments cleared
out, bringing some order back to
a city.
Seems simple on the surface.
Totally.
But what if one cleanup gets
called?
I don't know, civic pride maybe?
Savvy staging while another one
doing basically the same thing
gets labeled a federal
occupation or even even a coup.
Yeah, that's a huge difference.
It's a real head scratcher.
It is.
And that paradox, that mystery,
that's exactly what we're diving
into today.
So today, we're really digging
into this phenomenon.
It's fascinating.
We're going to compare two big
city cleanups, right?
One actually happened San
Francisco, led by Governor Gavin
Newsom.
And the other is, well, it's a
hypothetical scenario, but one
that's been talked about a lot.
Washington, DC under an order
from Donald Trump.
And on paper, the goals sound
pretty similar, don't they?
Cleaner city, safer, looks
better.
Exactly.
Similar aims, even some similar
methods, you know, clearing
things out.
But the public reaction, the
media coverage, couldn't be more
different.
Like polar opposites.
Yeah.
And our mission today really is
to try and unpack that, not just
what happened or, you know, what
might happen in the DC case, but
why?
Why are the perceptions so
incredibly different?
We want to explore this powerful
idea that maybe, maybe it's less
about the action itself, like
the objective facts on the
ground.
And more about who's doing it.
Exactly who's doing it and what
stories, what narratives we've
already built up around that
person.
It's about the the architecture
of narrative, how stories get
structured.
And hopefully this deep dive
will help you, our listeners,
start to spot these these
narrative frames when you're
reading the news or scrolling
through social media to look
past the headlines a bit.
We've got some really sharp
analysis to work with here
today, a piece that really cuts
through the noise and gets to
the heart of how these stories
get told, how they get framed,
and how we end up receiving
them.
Especially now you know when
everything feels so polarized.
It really makes you think, makes
you question those gut reactions
sometimes.
Definitely.
All right, so let's get into it.
Let's unpack this.
OK, so this tale of two brooms,
as the source material puts it,
let's start in San Francisco,
November 2023, right?
O picture this San Francisco, a
city that, let's be honest, had
very visible struggles with
homelessness, with street
conditions for quite a while.
Yeah, a major topic of
discussion.
Then, almost like flipping a
switch, it goes through this
incredibly rapid, super visible
transformation.
Like almost overnight sidewalk
encampments, these tent cities
that had been there for ages
just gone vanished.
Graffiti that was, you know,
everywhere.
Fresh paint covering it up,
Public murals getting touched
up, looking bright again.
Even the little things like
street planters suddenly having
flowers.
Right.
And the bike lanes.
But you're usually pretty grimy,
right?
They were scrubbed clean.
Like really clean.
It's a huge visual shift, all
done incredibly fast.
And what's really interesting
about the San Francisco
situation was Governor Newsom
himself.
Yeah, he was surprisingly open
about why it was happening then.
Yeah, he didn't really hide it.
Not at all.
He basically said, look, we're
doing this big cleanup because
company was coming over.
Meaning the APEC summit, right?
The Asia Pacific Economic
Cooperation meeting, Yeah.
And President Xi of China
visiting.
Exactly.
And he had that folksy line, the
one that got quoted everywhere.
You know, when you have company
coming over, you clean up the
house, Right.
And that little quip, that
analogy, it immediately framed
the whole thing, didn't it?
It made it sound, well,
practical, relatable, like
something anyone would do just.
Sprucing up for guests.
Yeah, not some big heavy-handed
policy change, more like
temporary stage setting for this
important international event.
Less about ideology, more about
hospitality.
So how did the press cover this
this massive quick overhaul?
Well, the coverage was, I'd say,
mixed, but the overall tone was
remarkably polite, almost
understanding, you know, a.
Little late, Yeah, that's a
good.
Word Major news outlets like the
AP and the New York Times, they
talked about it using terms like
civic pride or focused on the
optics.
Right, making the city look good
for the cameras for the world
leaders.
CNN even called it savvy
staging.
Almost like, hey, smart move,
governor.
Interesting.
So even the criticism wasn't
wasn't condemning the ACT
itself, not.
Really.
No.
When criticism came up, maybe
from conservatives asking why
only now, or from housing
advocates worried about where
the homeless people were moved,
the debate was mostly about
priorities.
Like shouldn't the city always
be this clean?
Or was this fair to the people
displaced?
Exactly.
But the fundamental right of the
city or the governor to do the
cleanup, that wasn't really the
core question being argued, was
sort of taken as a given that,
yeah, you clean up for company.
OK, so that polite reception,
even though it involved, you
know, moving homeless people,
clearing encampments, that
points to something deeper,
right, about the assumed
motives?
Absolutely.
That's the key.
The underlying assumption, the
frame was that Newsome's cleanup
was essentially cosmetic.
Strategic, sure, but ultimately
benign.
Not seen as a punishment or a
harsh new policy direction, no.
The why was just optics put on a
good show for the world leaders
make a good impression for
diplomacy.
And the subtext was kind of like
things will go back to normal
afterwards.
Pretty much.
Or at least the feeling was that
Newsome's basic sympathies, his
core political identity, was
still with the vulnerable.
You know, not with some kind of
permanent crackdown.
So it was like a temporary
performance.
Like setting a stage for a play.
Yeah, and this pre-existing
frame of Newsome as this
benevolent modernizer, a
standard Liberal Democrat,
allowed people, especially the
media, to give him the benefit
of the doubt.
His actions were seen through
that lens.
Pragmatism, not punishment.
OK, now let's shift gears.
Let's Fast forward to this other
scenario, the hypothetical one,
but very illustrative
Washington, DC, 2025, under an
order from Donald Trump.
Right, a very different picture
emerges.
The stated goals though?
Listen to this and smash and
grab robberies, break up open
air drug markets, clear
unpermitted St. encampments,
stop those illegal ATV and dirt
bike takeovers.
That sounds familiar, right?
Very similar goals to the San
Francisco situation.
Yeah, addressing disorder,
public safety.
And Trump's stated mission to
restore order to DC, which she
calls.
And this phrasing is probably
significant, our national living
room.
But here's the kicker, the
visuals.
It's not just sanitation crews.
The scenario describes the
brooms being accompanied by,
well, armored vehicles, federal
agents, maybe even the National
Guard.
Whoa.
OK, so the tools being used or
potentially used are vastly
different.
Totally different vibe, same
goal maybe, but a very different
image.
And that image, especially in
DC, hits different.
You have to remember Washington,
DC's unique status.
It's not a state.
Right.
It has home rule, but Congress
ultimately has the final say.
The president, too.
Exactly.
So when the federal government,
the president, sends in federal
agents or the military for what
looks like local policing, it
can easily be seen as overriding
the local government, the mayor,
the City Council.
It becomes about federal power
versus local control.
Precisely.
And that dynamic makes it
instantly more political, more
charged than a mayor cleaning up
their own city, especially the
federal military in the nation's
capital.
That carries a lot of historical
weight, a lot of baggage.
Yeah, You can see how that would
land differently and the
reaction described for this DC
scenario, it's described as
quote political DEFCON one
basically maximum alarm.
Sounds intense.
The language is incredibly
strong.
The Washington Post has imagined
calling it a federal occupation.
Occupation Well.
MSNBC running Chiron's.
You know, the text at the bottom
warning of urban martial law?
Now the source clarifies that's
rhetorical, not a legal term,
but still, yeah, it shows the
level of alarm.
It's a pretty stark picture of
fear, doesn't it?
Definitely think pieces
comparing it to Hungary or
Turkey, places often called
illiberal democracies, activist
groups staging die insurance,
blocking streets, holding signs
saying resist the coup, the.
Coup for cleaning streets.
That's the framing and the ACLU
warning it could be a trial run
for domestic authoritarianism.
It's just a completely different
universe of reaction compared to
San Francisco.
And if you think about why, I
mean putting military or
militarized federal forces onto
the streets of the city,
especially somewhere symbolic
like Lafayette Park.
Right across from the White
House historic protest spot.
Exactly.
That just conjures up completely
different images, different
historical echoes than, you
know, city workers painting over
graffiti.
It feels like seizing control of
the public space, not just
tidying it.
So for Trump, the Y is never
seen as just practical.
In this framing, no.
It's immediately assumed to be
ideological maximalist.
It's about punishment, about
erasing opposition, about
imposing his will.
So the frame is already set.
Trump equals authoritarian.
And once that frame locks in
what the source calls frame
lock, everything gets filtered
through it.
The broom isn't just a broom,
it's a weapon.
The street sweep isn't just
cleaning.
It's, you know, rhetorically
escalated to something far more
sinister.
Every action confirms the
pre-existing narrative.
The objective facts almost don't
matter anymore.
They struggle to get through
that frame, yeah.
So OK, we have this, the surface
level paradox.
Same basic impulse, right?
Make the city look better, feel
safer, more orderly if.
You have the stated goal.
Yet the verdicts are just worlds
apart.
One gets a nod, maybe some
criticism about timing, but it's
fundamentally accepted.
The other gets called the coup.
1 is a broom and a smile, the
other is seen as a baton and a
boot.
It's a really stark contrast.
It really is, and it makes you
ask that fundamental question.
Why does the fact that both
cleanups involve displacing
homeless people, enforcing laws
against camping, changing the
streetscape?
Why does that seem almost beside
the point in the narrative?
Yeah, the actual impact on
vulnerable people seems
secondary in the reaction story.
Exactly what does that tell us
about what really drives
perception?
It suggests The Who, the person
doing the action, and the why,
and we assume they're doing it
completely overpower the what.
The objective action gets lost.
It does.
And this paradox, this
difference, it points us towards
something deeper, this idea of
the architecture of narrative,
how the underlying story we tell
ourselves about someone shapes
everything else.
OK, let's unpack that more, this
architecture of narrative.
To really get it, maybe we need
to step back from Newsome and
Trump for a second and just look
at the mechanics of how stories
work, how they land.
Right.
It's not just about the event,
but the lens we use to see it.
The frame, exactly the frame.
That's the critical concept
here.
Think of it like like the
settings on a camera lens, or
maybe like a mental filter.
It's not just what information
gets through, but how that
information is colored, what's
brought into focus, what's left
blurry in the background.
And it determines how we assign
motives.
Absolutely.
It shapes what facts we pay
attention to and what intentions
we attribute to the person
acting.
Reminds me of that famous quote
from Frank Luntz, the pollster.
He said.
It's not what you say, it's what
they hear.
The frame is what dictates what
people hear, regardless of the
word spoken, if the invisible
structure that guides our
interpretation, often before we
even realize it.
Like the blueprint for the story
before it's even built?
That's a great way to put it.
Same materials, different
blueprints.
You get totally doodling
different feelings about them.
So applying that for Gavin
Newsom, the blueprint is already
there, right?
He's framed as the benevolent
modernizer.
Pretty much for a large part of
the media and the public,
especially those leaning
progressive, he's a known
entity, a Liberal Democrat.
He has the right allies, the
right enemies, according to that
worldview.
So that pre coding shapes how
his actions are seen.
Definitely.
It gives him that benefit of the
doubt.
We talked about his San
Francisco cleanup.
Even the disruptive parts gets
interpreted through that lens.
Cosmetic, strategic, temporary,
ultimately well-intentioned.
The why is assumed to be optics
diplomacy.
Right.
Not some deep seated desire to
punish or displace permanently.
The underlying assumption is his
heart's in the right place,
aligned with progressive values,
even if the methods get messy
for a specific temporary reason
like AIPAC.
So the frame allows for
complexity maybe?
Or forgiveness.
Or at least a left suspicious
interpretation of motive.
The actions are seen as
consistent, or at least not
fundamentally contradictory with
his established political
identity.
OK, contrast that with Donald
Trump.
The frame there is, well, very
different.
Dangerous outsider maybe, or
authoritarian?
Right.
He's often described less as a
politician and more as a totem,
A symbol that instantly divides
people, triggers really strong
reactions, almost like a tribal
flag.
For both sides, supporters and
detractors.
Exactly, and because of that
frame his why for doing
something like a city cleanup is
almost never allowed to be
simple or practical.
It has to be something bigger,
something more sinister.
In that view, it's.
Presumed to be ideological
maximalist about punishing
enemies, erasing dissent,
imposing control.
That's the immediate
interpretation dictated by the
frame.
And that's the frame lock you
mentioned.
Precisely once Trump equals
authoritarian becomes the locked
in frame, it's incredibly
resistant to contradictory
information.
Every action, no matter how
seemingly neutral or even
potentially positive, gets
filtered through that negative
lens.
The broom becomes a baton.
The sweet becomes an ethnic
cleansing, rhetorically
speaking.
The curfew becomes a step
towards fascism.
It's a powerful cognitive bias
at work.
Confirmation bias.
People see what confirms their
existing belief about him.
Which makes it almost impossible
to have a conversation about the
extra policy doesn't.
It it really does, the policy
itself gets lost.
It all becomes about the
perceived character and motives
of the actor.
You know, thinking about this,
cities and public space,
controlling them, cleaning them,
it's always been political,
hasn't it?
It's not just about sanitation.
Oh, absolutely.
Cities are theaters of power.
Who gets to be seen?
Who is made invisible?
Who decides?
That's always been political.
I'm thinking back to like Rudy
Giuliani in New York in the 90s
cleaning up Times Square.
That's a classic example.
He launched that huge effort,
right?
Broken windows, policing, going
after minor offenses, clearing
out the squeegee men, the sex
shops.
And crime did drop.
Tourism boomed.
He became America's mayor, a
huge success story in many ways.
Undeniably.
But there was another side to
that story, too, wasn't there?
Yeah, the criticism that his
tactics were harsh, that they
criminalized poverty, targeted
minorities.
Exactly so even Giuliani's
success was framed very
differently depending on who you
asked.
It was effective but also
controversial.
Newsome's clean up in SF kind of
sits in that tradition, but the
framing was different.
Because it was temporary tied to
APEC.
I think so.
It was framed as pragmatic
pageantry, not a permanent
shift.
The homeless were relocated, not
erased.
The frame of diplomatic
necessity soften the edges.
Whereas the hypothetical Trump
DC operation that's framed
completely differently, not as
pageantry, but.
As as an existential rewrite,
yeah.
Who controls the Capitol?
He's the president overriding
local government.
That feels different.
And the military visuals,
that's.
Huge military uniforms in
somewhere like Lafayette Park
that evokes completely different
historical fears and memories
than, say, the Department of
Public Works.
So cleaning Lafayette Park under
armed guard isn't just cleaning.
In that frame, no.
It's seizing the public stage.
It's asserting dominance.
It's turning a civic space into
a symbol of federal power,
potentially authoritarian power.
The location and the tools
transform the meaning entirely.
This is where it gets really
kind of concerning, I think.
This frame lock.
Once these narratives harden,
they seem almost impossible to
change.
Like fossils?
Yeah.
New facts just seem to chip away
at the edges.
They don't break the mold.
And it leads to this crazy
asymmetry you give the examples
earlier.
Right.
If Newsom the benevolent
Modernizr clears an encampment,
it's seen as a tough but
necessary choice.
Maybe temporary.
His motives are trusted within
that frame.
But if Trump the authoritarian
were to do something seemingly
positive like fund homeless
shelters?
The frame dictates suspicion.
Is it a trick?
A way to consolidate power?
A personality cult.
The positive action gets
reinterpreted through the
negative lens.
It's not about the what anymore,
it's purely about The Who.
So this has huge implications
for how we even talk about
politics, doesn't it?
Policy gets sidelined.
Completely.
The focus shifts from tactics,
outcomes, effectiveness, you
know, the stuff we should be
debating to personalities and
motives.
And we assign those motives with
such certainty like we have a
crystal ball.
Clairvoyant certainty, as the
source puts it.
Yeah.
And we see this bias everywhere.
Think about Trump's deportation
talk, he says.
Deport everyone undocumented.
But how is it often reported or
perceived?
Often softened framed is just
targeting violent criminals,
even though that's not his full
stated policy.
That frame makes it sound less
extreme, maybe more acceptable
to some.
It twists the actual stated goal
to fit a narrative.
Or look at Newsome again, his
usual critics on homelessness.
They went quiet during APEC
week.
Why?
Because the frames shifted.
Seems like it.
The frame of diplomatic
necessity hosting world leaders
temporarily overrode their usual
criticisms.
It made the sweep seem
different, less like a policy
failure, more like a temporary,
unavoidable measure.
Shows how context can activate
different frames.
So what are the stakes here?
If we end up with two sets of
rules for the same action,
depending only on who's doing
it, that sounds dangerous.
It's incredibly dangerous for a
healthy democracy, I think,
because legitimacy stops being
about process, you know, are the
rules followed?
Is the policy effective?
Is it constitutional?
And it becomes about.
About tribe Is this person on my
team?
If yes, their actions are
legitimate, even if I wouldn't
accept them from the other side.
If no, their actions are
illegitimate, even if they're
doing something I might normally
agree with.
Legitimacy becomes tribal, not
procedural.
Exactly.
And that raises a huge question.
How does that erode just basic
civic trust?
How can we have functional self
government if we can't even
agree on a common set of rules
or evaluate actions based on
merit rather than personality?
We just end up shouting about
motives instead of debating
substance.
Pretty much we get stuck in
these endless loops arguing
about character instead of
consequences.
So what does this all mean for
us, For people trying to make
sense of the world?
It feels like the next time we
see a cleanup or any big
government.
Action.
The interpretation is already
baked in.
Yeah, it means the next broom,
no matter who's holding it,
might not be seen as just
cleaning anymore.
It might be seen as conquering
depending on which tribe you
belong to.
The action itself loses its
meaning, overshadowed by the
frame around the actor.
That's the power and the
potential danger of this
narrative architecture.
So wrapping this up, what we've
really seen today is just how
incredibly powerful these frames
are, these invisible lenses.
They shape everything.
How we see actions, how we judge
leaders, whether something as
heroic or tyrannical, can depend
entirely on the frame, not the
action itself.
It's less about the objective
reality and more about the story
we're told or the story we
already believe about the person
involved.
Yeah.
And hopefully this deep dive
encourages you, everyone
listening, to be maybe a bit
more aware, to become more
attuned to the frames operating
in the news you read, the
conversations you have.
The pause before reacting.
Exactly.
Look beyond that immediate gut
feeling the headline and ask,
OK, wait, is this reaction
really about the action itself,
or is it more about the actor?
What assumptions am I making
here?
What narrative is being pushed?
It's not just academic, right?
It's a tool for thinking more
clearly.
It's a vital tool, I think, for
navigating the world today, for
trying to have more productive
conversations.
So maybe the final thought to
leave everyone with is this.
The next time you see a news
report or get into a debate,
whether it's about something
small like a city cleanup or
something huge like a national
policy, just ask yourself that
question.
Is this really about the broom,
or is it actually about whose
hand is holding it?
What are the unspoken
assumptions here, the narratives
driving the reaction?
And what does that mean for how
we actually understand what's
happening around us?